we looked at the general form of a
quadratic something like this and we
went from there we completed the square
and up popped magically the quadratic
formula okay now this year remember is
the general form of quadratic the judo
fool okay because you can express every
quadratic in this form for some values
of a B and C okay now you might think
okay what are the forms on it now to get
to answer that question I want to go
back to when we were looking at straight
line cuz we're doing Lydian functions
okay so if that's straight sorry that's
a general form of a parabola record
genetic what's the general form of a
straight line and it's very similar
right if I say why what's the general
thank you okay so this is general form
it allows us to make a nice easy
comparison between any of the different
equations but it doesn't tell us very
much about the straight line right which
is why we have all of these other forms
so for instance if I did have y equals
what might you expect on the right hand
side what might be a common did you see
that MX plus B yeah now this form has
eight eight right what's it called this
is general form so we call this one
radians
intercept or what intercept it's the Y
intercepts right so in other words
before minutes in tells you different
features but this wasn't the only form
that we learnt give me another one
it's good so again a new form that you
name what's this one called it's called
point radiant for right we're done we've
done grain intercept okay because x1 y1
is the point in Pasha's through and M is
its gradient okay now
you remember the whole point of these
was you write it in a particular form
based on what you want to do with it
right just as a quick note or what you
have so all of these are geometric
features this would though just by did
not tell you any geometric features its
astoundingly useful we use this all the
time what do we use it for so for
example if you want the distance between
a point in the line
pull it out for you what is this what is
it
it's gonna be okay good
okay so if you want to do this you must
absolutely have it in general form
otherwise you kind of up the creek
without a paddle all right sir so now
here's my Avenue into going from here to
here now this is a general form of a
quadratic okay what other forms might be
useful because this fool doesn't tell
you well it almost doesn't tell you
anything geometrically about is
prevalent does tell you one thing so no
one tells you right away it tells you
just in the same way that this does it
tells you what the y-intercept is it's
just the constant term okay yeah okay
sir so if I say this if I say that okay
then really what's going on is like this
isn't this is my equation of a problem
right so what you're really saying is
this right which we're going to get to
in a second this is shifted which way up
or down it's up or down right because
it's why it's vertical it's up its up
right just like a we're gonna get to
this in a second right just like you see
over here I'm going up well if I move to
the other side it's still the same thing
it's still going off right it's just
that this clarifies that it's modifying
the why not
the exes okay keep thinking about it now
like I said general form not great for
seeing features okay a you support which
you try to work toward a lot is a
factorized form right so for example the
one we did this morning
oops now why is it factorized form
useful what's valuable about it
good just like well this one right you
get two minutes it's an external why
this one gives you both x-intercepts
right so that's a plus right that's why
we invest so much energy your previous
use and factorizing okay but this unlike
all of these has a big problem
notice what's the problem with a
factorized form yeah okay yes sure so I
mean I could give any table right I
could say generally speaking something
like this okay so this has two roots
alpha and beta right excuse me and that
factor of a at the front just like the
factor of a up here has the function of
stretching it out or squashing it down
okay so I can account for that but
there's still a bigger problem okay yeah
uh-huh it's just that you say half I'm
not gonna comment on that I'm just
interested by it I'm just going to say
lots of quadratics don't have factorize
forms I'll give you a simple Michael
he's the simplest one I can think of you
cannot factorize this with any real
numbers there's nothing you can do with
it so it doesn't have a form like this
with real numbers right why is that what
what is this crap yeah it doesn't have
any real roots right it's this guy okay
so being that a whole bunch of
quadratics do not have roots right many
quadratics cannot exist in their form
right whereas every straight line can be
put in one of these forms
right because they will accept a
horizontal but they're visible they're
always going to have a couple intercepts
they're always putting possible pair of
points cost an infinite number of points
they're always gonna have a great yet
etc right but this is kind of a hole
right so that's why it doesn't fold week
a degree oh these are all the other
things we learn there is one geometric
feature only one that every single
parabola has and I've brought it right
there it's in your hands first
okay well yeah it does have a
y-intercept but I kind of already know
what that is right so I don't need to
put in any special form to get a whiny
set down on that laughter we suggest a
cab do have an axis of symmetry right I
can get that from anywhere so I suppose
like you can get - beyond - way out of
that right and that will still be it
okay
the really important feature just over
the line of like intercepts over here or
a point or a gradient is that guy right
there there but X every parabola even if
it's like up down sideways it's always
going to have a vertex so therefore
here's my heading right in case you were
saving it virt ax C's is the plural
vertex a senior